Tesla the long-awaited a more affordable
electric car could start rolling off the
assembly line as early as Friday
Tesla co-founder and CEO Elon Musk
tweeted that the new model 3 passed its
regulatory requirements two weeks ahead
of schedule he says the first 30 cars
will be delivered to customers on July
28th the company expects to produce
20,000 Model 3 cars a month by December
Tim Stevens is editor-in-chief of the
automotive website Roadshow at our
partners CNET Tim joins us this morning
okay Tim Tesla doesn't really
mass-produced cars what does this mean
for consumers and do you think they can
pull it off right this is really the
maker break moment for Tesla everything
they've done until now the Roadster the
Model S and Model X it's all been
building the foundation for this car
their first truly mass-produced
affordable car priced in the mid $30,000
so this could really change things for a
lot of people it's an affordable Evie
it's a great-looking Evie and it should
be a lot of fun to drive to and those
are things we don't really see in the
market right now but if it doesn't work
for testing there's a lot of pressure on
this is there not I mean based on where
they've been and where they want to go
right there's a huge amount of pressure
here for sure Tesla has been making
really nice vehicles very high-priced 60
70 80 thousand dollars and up with with
good range of good performance but again
not something that everybody could
afford but really what Tesla looking to
grow as a company they need a
mass-market product and that's exactly
what this is meant to be they're looking
at trying to get 1/2 million in
production next year 85,000 this past
year how realistic is that that's a huge
hockey stick we're going to grow and
ultimately they've done a lot of things
to the model 3 to make that possible the
Model S and the Model X are pretty
complicated cars to build with a model 3
they've really simplified things
streamline the production process a lot
to enable them to build a lot more of
these cars they've got a massive battery
factory in Nevada as well that she's
helped to but still that's a pretty
aggressive press the battery has been
the issue with the other production
recently hasn't it right so they built
this massive factory in Nevada called
the Giga factory which is gonna be
producing hundreds of thousands of
batteries for them but ultimately
there's still the things like material
shortages that they need to work around
and other things like that that could
ultimately stunt that growth a little
bit its optimistic but I do think we'll
be seeing tons of building a lot more
cars I've been obsessed with this cars
and I'm not a car girl I'm just not a
car girl on through blood doesn't have a
third row seating as a mom it helps with
car pools but I
hey I do like that third row but you
know the fact that it's electric do you
think there's enough of a consumer base
of people who really want to invest in
this I definitely think that there will
be going forward there hasn't been this
far because most EDS have been priced
forty thousand dollars and up and
they've had range you know around 100
miles or less and those are two
compromises that you need to get over
but with a car that's priced under forty
thousand dollars and that can do over
200 miles of range suddenly don't we're
going to worry about finding a charging
station and ultimately it's priced
comparably to any other car the average
new price of a car in the u.s. is
$32,000 so it was right on that same
target Tim what do you think of the
Eevee's you've driven so far they're all
great the throttle response is really
nice it's actually fun to drive on the
reliability it's generally pretty good
but one of the big things that a lot of
people think about its service there's
really no oil change is gonna Tory about
transmission problem is to cool it flush
it anything like that what's so they're
nice to live with Tim as long as you've
got that charging station you got
anything for them an important thing Tim
Stevens thank you appreciate it